what's going on guys this is rob and as
you can see i have a set and for those
of you guys who are undoubtedly going to
ask this is marvel shadows by alex ross
i bought it at san diego and i had to
use it for a set piece having said that
i'm currently recording on the canon
c200 camera kind of a fun thing for all
you aspiring youtube content creators
out there who are looking to record
yourselves at some point in the future i
will be getting rid of this camera and
when i do i'll be giving it away to
somebody for free and i'll be replacing
it with like a c70 or maybe a c500 mark
ii i'm not 100 sure yet i've also got my
laptop here which for those of you guys
who are on comics explained you'll see
this video on geek culture explain for
those of you guys on geek culture
explain you'll see this video on comics
explain on the comments explained side
you'll see me use my laptop from time to
time specifically when i'm doing
character explanations because i'm old
and i can't remember things the way that
i used to
just the price you pay for getting older
i guess you'll also see little set
pieces of course right here i've got
giant size not giant size x-men volume
two issue number one one of the four
variant covers that i possess this one's
my favorite one a lot of people ask me
over at comics explain they say rob do
you collect comics not anymore for real
and for true not anymore unless it's a
particular comic that i find very very
interesting i don't really collect
physical comics i usually buy digitally
and then just read them from there i
guess the bigger question here is what
change will you notice when it comes to
youtube videos well on the comics
explained side with the exception of me
just kind of intermittently popping in
over the course of a video really more
for character explanation videos than
anything else you won't really notice a
difference on the geek culture explained
side you'll notice a little bit of a
difference you'll of course see a more
professional set with the videos that
i'm creating but what you'll also notice
is that we have other people who have
been been creating content on the
youtube channel red muffler man is a guy
named gordon and gordon is basically the
first person that i ever hired on geek
culture explained those you guys who
came from comics explained you remember
him as my editor he was the first editor
that i ever hired and the guy that
literally saved me from burnout that's
kind of an issue that we were running
into recently on geek culture explained
as much as i love producing content on
that youtube channel the reality is that
i was getting burned out and i need
other people to be able to produce
content on the channel to keep myself
from getting burned out now i'm not
telling you this as some kind of a
apology for anything like that i'm
letting you know that's the way things
are because we have two options either
we can just continue on the current
course where i'm the only one who
uploads content and then i get burned
out and we shut the whole thing down or
we bring a couple other people on who
create content from time to time and uh
we keep the whole train going so i want
to keep the whole train going so the
thing about this is that gordon's going
to be doing editorials and you've seen a
few of those already i love the videos
he makes and he's done a fantastic job
what you're also going to see here is a
guy named karan who you have not
formally been introduced to but he is
the guy that actually created the video
really recorded everything edited the
video put it together the whole nine
yards at least i think he did maybe alex
did alex is the editor for geek culture
explain i lose track but uh quran is the
one who put together the whole we
survived hall h video so uh you haven't
been formally introduced with the
exception of a couple shorts he hasn't
really made content for the channel per
se but you're gonna see him floating
around here as well and then as usual
you're also gonna see me creating
content don't worry my beautiful mug's
gonna be here just like it's always been
and i'll be here with my sexy voice to
brighten up your day with my my theories
on geek culture explained that are
always wrong
and i never care because it's more about
having fun i do like the idea of having
a more professional looking set i think
it just brings a level of profession to
the youtube channel that it somebody
just hasn't had for a little while i
think it changes things and honestly it
makes me feel good to have this so let
me know what you guys think about this
down in the comments section for those
of you guys on comments explain let me
know what you think about this in the
comics flame video those of you guys who
are on geek culture explain let me know
what you think about this in the geek
culture explain video and uh yeah i will
catch you all later
peace
my bad